i'm geraldo rivera i'm emily compagno
and i'm eric shawn this is a fox news
rundown
wednesday may 4th 2022 i'm lisa brady it
feels like a big supreme court decision
but it was just a leak suggesting the
court might overturn roe vs wade enough
to kick the abortion debate into high
gear it's devastating to the court
because
it has been that place that we have had
confidence in washington and this really
chips away at a time when people are
losing faith in our institutions
i'm dave anthony more drivers are
flipping the switch going electric fed
up with the rising cost of filling up my
gas bill went down about 400
and my electric bill really only went up
three to thirty dollars like literally
three zero and i'm david marcus i've got
the final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
judging from the reaction you'd think
the u.s supreme court had just ended
abortion rights
this after the leak of a draft opinion
written by justice samuel alito in a
case centered on mississippi's 15-week
abortion ban explaining why roe versus
wade the 1973 decision that legalized
abortion nationwide should be overturned
the draft was first reported monday
night by politico just a few hours later
the democratic national committee was
out with a statement that reproductive
rights would be on the ballot this fall
by tuesday morning president biden was
also calling on voters to pick
pro-choice candidates and calling the
draft opinion radical if the rationale
of the decision as released
were to be sustained
a whole range of rights are in question
the president wants abortion rights
legislation to make roe federal law
democrats are going to fight this
decision all the way for as long as it
takes senate majority leader chuck
schumer says he's outraged by the draft
and by republican reaction accusing them
of ducking the issue by focusing on the
leak but senate gop leader mitch
mcconnell says liberals want to override
impartiality with intimidation they want
to elevate mob rule
over
the rule of law chief justice john
roberts says he directed the marshal of
the court to investigate calling the
leak a singular and egregious breach of
trust but also vowing that it will not
undermine the court's integrity the
court is also emphasizing it's not a
decision and doesn't represent any
member's final position this is
exceptionally
unusual shannon bream is the fox news
chief legal correspondent and anchor of
fox news at night i've covered the court
for 15 years and never seen anything
even remotely like this
so it was the one institution in
washington that you expected was sort of
airtight it has been in my entire time
covering this and for decades before
that it's not that leaks never happen
but to have a
draft opinion which the court has
confirmed is legit actually leaked in
full
is kind of astonishing
the chief justice has said that
you know it is going to be investigated
what does that process
look like i mean are they they must be
really angry right now behind the scenes
i think this is a tough one for the
chief his duty to protect and his
passion to protect the court is very
evident so the fact that this has
happened on his watch has got to be very
disturbing to him
we've had a couple leaks this year on
much more minor situations we had mask
gates in which we were told there was
reporting that justice sotomayor had
asked people to wear masks and the
justice gorsuch had declined and there
was a tiff and i quickly found out that
was not true which was confirmed by
statements from justice's gorsuch
sotomayor and then the chief justice
himself so it's been a busy year on that
front the marshal's office is going to
be heading up this investigation and the
chief appears to have full confidence
they will get to the bottom of it so we
will now stand by to see exactly what
the court finds
the biden administration's argument in
support of roe versus wade is the 14th
amendment's concept of personal liberty
that there's been a long precedent in
favor of that and against government
interference with intensely personal
decisions now the leaked draft has
justice alito writing it's time to heed
the constitution and return the issue of
abortion to the states in other words
it's a right not guaranteed by the
constitution is that the crux
of this debate and does that then make
the viability issue the timing of an
abortion
a moot point
yeah i mean i think you do get to the
heart of this at whether or not there is
a constitutional right to abortion and
even those who were supportive of roe
and that would consider themselves
pro-choice there were those who felt it
didn't have strong legal underpinnings
so the way that it was reasoned out or
tackled
left it open potentially to being
chipped away at or overruled at some
point i mean justice ginsburg was in
that camp who felt like it wasn't
decided in precisely the way she thought
had the best legal reasoning that would
protect that decision down the line
so at the heart of this this draft from
justice alito says he finds no
constitutional right he says the court
in roe glossed over it and did not
carefully consider
and find that there was an actual
constitutional right to this procedure
and so
that's basically his bottom line is both
row and casey the follow-up case have
got to go because they don't have strong
legal underpinnings and constitutional
underpinnings and again it doesn't mean
that abortion will be outlawed it does
mean that states are going to have a lot
more latitude if the final opinion ends
up being along the lines of this draft
president biden is suggesting that this
would throw other privacy related issues
into question for instance could florida
now outlaw same-sex marriage if this is
essentially being kicked to the states
i don't see room for that in this 98
page draft again what we end up getting
is the final opinion who knows how it's
been nuanced or tweaked or or what
different iterations it's gone through
the court it seems here in justice leado
writing seems to say that this is a
different situation in that this is a
quote life or a fetal life that is being
held in the balance and that's how you
have to make the assessment about
who gets to make these decisions so i
know there's a lot of fear on the left
that there will be some undoing of other
decisions i think this is historic in
nature if it actually turns out that the
final opinion does overrule roe but i
think that to extrapolate that it's
going to rip apart all kinds of other
privacy
detailed rights i think is a bit
overblown at this point we'll have to
see
yeah i mean what about something like
the death penalty even could that be
reconsidered based on the the
constitutional right to end a life yeah
i mean there there has been a lot of
pushback on the issue of the death
penalty the last few years of the court
and justice breyer who's getting ready
to leave is one of those who has really
i mean the court is free to reconsider
anything it's decided in the past and
like i said earlier there are those
across the legal and political spectrum
who thought that roe was on shaky ground
because of the original way that it was
decided
and it looks potentially like if this
final opinion tracks uh with the draft
from justice toledo looks like it's on
track to do that to say roe was never
rightly decided and we are now
correcting what they view as that
mistake
how much higher is the burden when
you're talking about possibly
overturning precedent are there specific
metrics or tests for that to help make
that decision
yeah definitely when the justices are
looking this idea of starry decisis they
will walk through a calculation to
assess whether or not it is time to
overturn an earlier decision so there
are all kinds of things that they will
consider here and that you know have
sort of been walked through
the nature of the error the quality of
the reasoning of the original um piece
which in this case would be row
the workability of rules disruptive area
to other areas of the law and the
absence of concrete reliance on it so
there's definitely a framework that they
walk through for this and
injustice um i was going to say scalia
and justice alito in his assessment
walking through those steps he thinks
the court is justified in overturning
this case of landmark precedence
this leak would seem to put even more
pressure on the justices because this
you know has the potential to be such a
monumental decision republican senator
susan collins of maine came out with a
statement saying if this is the final
decision it would be completely
inconsistent with what justice gorsuch
and justice kavanaugh said in their
hearings and in meetings in her office
does that surprise you
well i can't speak to what happened in
their conversations in her office only
those people will know
but what publicly these recent nominees
have said has has left room for this to
happen they have said that they respect
the idea of precedent and
the workings of the court and the way
that it operates but i never heard any
of these recent nominees say under no
circumstances would i ever consider
overturning roe v wade so
i feel like
nominees are very careful whether
they're nominated by democrats or
republicans to leave that tiniest window
open to say
yes i have great respect for president i
don't foresee any scenario in which
we're going to revisit this but
you know there is a scenario in which
the court has looked back at decisions
and said we got it wrong the first time
senate republican leader mitch mcconnell
says the court should tune out bad faith
noise and feel free to do their job and
that would actually seem like a
prerequisite for the justices
um is it harder to do that today than in
decades past or is like you know the
pressure just different types of
pressure
you know i doubt many of these justices
spend a lot of time on twitter or on
social media i'm not saying they don't
lurk around maybe i don't think it's a
big part of their day and there are some
of them who read a lot of the media
coverage of the court there are others
who want nothing to do with it because
they don't want to be influenced or
swayed and you know in this draft
opinion justice toledo talks about the
fact that we have to follow the law and
make the decisions as we as jurists see
them we can't be worried about what the
public fallout will be
um and i think he's putting down a
marker there saying that's not the way
the court should operate there's
certainly a lot of pressure on them i
mean you think about senate majority
leader chuck schumer just last year
stood on the steps of the supreme court
and specifically invoked the names of
justices cavan on gorsuch and said you
know you're going to reap the whirlwind
and you will pay if you make these quote
awful decisions so
you know even elected members of
congress high-ranking ones have tried to
send messages that many people view as
intimidation to the justices but as the
chief justice said in his response in
his public statement on this this is not
going to affect the
workings of the court we're going to do
our jobs and i think he's very committed
to making sure they all do that
what's your take on the potential
motivation behind this leak because two
kind of basic schools of thought seem to
be emerging in terms of theories
one being that it was designed to put
pressure on the justices not to overturn
roe and the other
being that you know maybe it's a
political move
fueled by democrats wanting to have a
midterm campaign issue
you know any of those things is possible
you only the leaker knows and that
person made a very specific choice
because this is a very dangerous thing
to do if you care about the integrity of
the court but they clearly made their
calculations for whatever reason to move
ahead with this um i had someone email
me a few minutes ago and said well what
if it was somebody on the right who
wanted this to be the final opinion and
wanted to get it out there and was
afraid that um you know one of the
conservatives was going to peel off and
try to write a more watered-down opinion
i mean the theories are endless and i'm
confident i actually think that the
court will get to the bottom of where
this came from it's such a small
universe of people who would have access
to this opinion and much of it is done
in hard copy format rather than emails
and that kind of thing to protect
against this kind of thing but i'm just
as fascinated as everybody else to see
exactly where this goes
how devastating
could it be for the court as an
institution
if someone behind the scenes even
has been part of something that is
politically motivated on the left or the
right
yeah i mean honestly i think it's
devastating to the court because
it has been that place that we have had
confidence in washington and this really
chips away at a time when people are
losing faith in our institutions
and the court is a place that you want
to view as down the middle judges and
justices who actually decide strictly on
what they think the law means and
interpret it on that alone and not based
on emotion or public pressure or
anything else so um regardless of where
you stand on this particular issue or
whether you're happy or not happy about
this opinion i think it's really sad to
think
that this breach has happened at the
court at a time when people really need
to have confidence in their institutions
this is only early may now already we've
got protesters outside the supreme court
on something you know something that
wasn't expected to be a decision until
june do you think this will hasten the
release of the final decision even
though they say they're just going to
keep working and not let this affect
anything
you know what my gut believes we're
going to get this earlier than last week
of june which is when we normally would
wait for the big landmark cases of the
term
i think because there are real concerns
about the safety of all of the justices
and especially those who would be
conservatives who would have signed on
to what listen has no import and no
force at all right now it's a draft
opinion
you know does that happen in a day or
two i don't think so does it happen
short of the last week of june i think
so
fox news chief legal correspondent and
anchor of fox news at night shannon
breme thanks so much for your time
great to be with you
this is david marcus with your fox news
commentary coming up
the cost to fill up is being pumped back
up gas has risen about a penny a day the
past week with triple a's national
average for regular around 420 a gal and
that is just 13 cents from its record
high in march when president biden said
the reason for that
is because of putin's war blaming
russia's leader though republicans have
also blamed the president senator ted
cruz tells fox they've decided
politically let's blame this train wreck
of a biden energy policy on vladimir
putin well you know what the gasoline
prices had rid has ridden 48 percent
before putin invaded ukraine regardless
of the reason the high cost has driven
some people to shift gears and go
electric
kelly blue book reports in the first
three months of this year americans
bought nearly twice as many electric
vehicles than the same period in 2021
and for the first time five percent of
all vehicle sales were electric a trend
the white house likes it has a goal of
half of all vehicles in the usb electric
by 2030 and to that end a few months ago
the president offered five billion
dollars in grants to states to make more
charging stations available and on
monday the buy then administration
pledged a 3.1 billion dollars in funding
opportunity announcement to build up the
supply chain for the manufacturing of
the battery now energy secretary
jennifer granholm adds those who want to
apply for it like businesses who are
interested in either teaming together
potentially for a processing facility or
on their own that they will have to
supply a match of the funding so the 3.1
billion ends up becoming 6.2 billion
there are several automakers producing
electrical vehicles tesla leads the way
by far its sales surged 81 percent in
the first quarter in kelly blue book
also reports three in four electric
vehicles sold so far this year in the
u.s are teslas
ford is also making them with an all new
truck f-150 lightning is one of the
first full-size pickup trucks on the
market for
an electric ev linda zhang is ford's
chief engineer on that f-150 lightning
we have one shot to get it right because
that this first impression for our
customers matter particularly with gas
prices increasing this truck
starting at under forty thousand 000
is just such a great
proposition for our customers and that
is before any uh federal or state
incentives you must have some people
though who are wary right i mean as you
mentioned it's a popular truck
some people say i like the truck the way
i have it i don't want to lose any
maybe they fear they lose power or the
ability to tow or all the things they do
with their truck
what do you say when people give you
that i would say that this truck gives
them all of that plus more and that's
exactly what we base this the
development of this truck on it is a
series and with that it's built for
tough we made sure that from a
capability reliability durability
perspective we go through the same
regiment that we do with any truck this
one tows up to ten thousand pounds a
payload of over two thousand pounds now
and
the performance is even more fantastic
zero to 60 in mid four seconds with near
instant torque of 775 foot-pounds and
580 horsepower so definitely
they won't be customers will not have to
give up anything in terms of performance
or capability and then on top of that
because we're able to go electric we're
giving our customers even more with all
the features that can really only be
brought with electrification like this
capability to be able to back up their
homes as a backup generator for days on
end
with the intelligent backup power or pro
power on board which allows them to take
the truck and use it as a generator on
wheels anywhere they want you
so um you know that along with the
performance and just the fact that
without an engine we also have this
enormous space in the front of the truck
called the mega power frunk
frunk is front trunk
it is 400 liters of volume and 400
pounds of payload enough to be able to
put two full-size golf clubs inside of
this
mega power front so just a fantastic
space and only capable because of the
fact that it's an ev all right all right
so where you sit without the engine so
where is the mechanism in an electric
vehicle
the battery sits um underneath the cab
basically between the wheels between the
front wheels and the rear wheels um and
then there's two dual electric motors
that run the propulsion okay uh between
the battery and the motor
all right everyone in these electric
fields vehicles always wants to know
how many miles can i drive before i have
to plug it in
yeah so our extended range batteries
provide our customers with 320 miles of
full range and i think the one thing to
think about that's a little bit
different in this case is with an ev
most of our customers charge at home
with a level 2 charger with extended
range we actually provide our customers
with an 80 amp charger that they can use
and with that it charges overnight to
get you 320 miles every morning if
that's what you want okay um and then
you know for the longer road trips
we have access to 90 000 charging plugs
around
north america so lots of opportunity to
charge even on the go now that's the
issue that people always also talk about
when they put up a barrier to buying an
electric vehicle i know
at a shopping mall near where i live
there's a whole row
of these tesla stations right but i
don't see too many places anywhere in
like you know what like gas stations or
just that are generally just electric
charging stations how much more are we
going to see of that in the coming years
well that will definitely increase that
infrastructure is building but i mean
even now between last year and this year
we've gone up from 60 000 plus to the 90
thousand so i mean that's a huge
increase in infrastructure and it will
only continue to accelerate
okay the next thing is
you know obviously we know how much it
feel it costs to fill up with gas
especially with over four dollars a
gallon nowadays
how much
does it cost me to plug in an electric
car to my home in energy costs every
time i plug it in
oh it's definitely a lot less i mean i
um i switched over to amaki i can
probably give you better from like just
a personal example right but i switched
over to a ford mustang maki a few years
ago and at that point my gas bill went
down about 400
and my electric bill really only went up
three thirty dollars like literally
three zero so ten times the delta um in
terms of savings and
it you know particularly with um ev
charging at you know in low peak hours
at night if you leverage that rate um it
is just a fantastic rate when i go to a
charging station well how much time
should i expect to to sit there i mean
at least there's one thing about the gas
station it takes only a couple minutes
and you're gone and you have a full tank
how long does it take if you have to go
to a charging station in the middle of a
trip somewhere how long do you have to
sit there and is there like a credit
card you put it in and it charges you by
the by how much you get out i'm new at
this so please help me yes i mean you're
exactly right so actually with fordpass
um we we uh
link the communication between the ev
charging and uh your system so all of
that's kind of pre-programmed in almost
in a way
to make it convenient for the customer
but yes you just plug it in and uh let
it go and it it goes but to go from say
15 to 80 some percent
we're looking at about you know low 40
minutes so a lot of the times what i've
found personally again is you know at
that point um it's perfect because my my
family needs to stop anyway i need to
stop for a quick break we grab a bite to
eat and by the time we're ready to go
the car or truck is already charged up
ready to go to
another one that i had heard someone
asked this question when there was a
snow storm there were a bunch of cars
stuck on a highway for hours and hours
and hours people ran out of gas and they
were stranded and it was it was a very
very difficult time people spent like a
day there
what would happen if your electric
vehicle was a part of that and it
happened for you when you were stuck how
long would the juice last would you run
out of electricity like the cars run out
of gas
um i mean it's definitely possible but i
think one of the great things about this
truck is that if this truck was in that
storm it would actually be one of those
vehicles helping others right because of
the pro power on board and the charging
capability
this
we have such a
big battery underneath this truck it can
keep a home comfortably backed up for
days on end so if you think about it
from that perspective we should
definitely be able to keep the car
running for multiple days as well right
so if you're not driving it it's going
to hold the charge
right and i think you know the use that
you're talking about would just be
climate to keep the you know the
passengers comfortable which
is efficient right so
i mean you've been doing this for a long
time as an engineer
the 320 mile range that you have now on
this on this ford
in 10 years in 20 years do you think
it's going to be a lot more than that i
think
that that's where you know
infrastructure will help us along the
way and down the road it's only going to
get better because even with iphones now
you know the batteries improved and i
can last uh a much longer time now than
i could you know even five years ago so
um i know everyone's got range anxiety
right now but once they get in the
vehicle once they experience it once
they lift with it for a little bit the
style of how you drive and how you live
changes a little bit to really in a
positive way
i know there's no oil change in an
electric vehicle so what what kind of
maintenance do i expect from an electric
versus a traditional
yeah no that's a great point that's
another reason why total cost of
ownership is great right you don't have
to go in for oil changes every 10 000
miles
for us it's really just uh tire
rotations
because
there's really nothing that needs to be
changed until we get to about 150 000
miles i know you've had a lot of demand
for this vehicle how many people want
one this this new ford f-150
yeah um so we actually hit over 200 000
reservations last december at which
point we had to pause our reservation
and even this year we know that there's
been tremendous interest in the vehicle
so i think uh the you know the interest
is definitely there and at ford we're
trying to meet that demand we've
increased our capacity for the lightning
and we're going to be at
150 000 units running rate in 23.
linda zhang chief engineer for the ford
all-electric f-150 lightning thank you
very much for being with us thanks for
having me
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
david marcus
what's on your mind the rise of the
parent this primary power in american
politics has been stunning over the past
year in virginia glenn younkin surged
into the governor's mansion in no small
part owing to his battle against
critical race theory in the schools in
florida governor ron desantis signed a
sweeping and popular bill to protect
young kids from trans ideology in the
classroom
both of these politicians and many more
republicans have been bullied by the
anger and frustration of parents who to
borrow an old phrase from the lefties
are chanting whose kids our kids
but if this is proving to be a boon to
the gop it is an absolute morass for the
democrat party which can't even decide
its actual positions on education
take white house press secretary jen
saki i asked recently about florida's
parental rights bill which her boss joe
biden not only disagrees with but calls
hateful and bigoted saki expressed
disdain for desantis measure and added
this
i also think there is not a big record
of there being either sex education or
extensive gender identity education in
these schools adding that it's an issue
i don't think exists
if that sounds familiar it should it is
the exact same lie the democrats use to
avoid even discussing the role the
critical race theory clearly plays in
our public schools they blithely insist
that crt is only taught in law school
alighting the fact that it is absolutely
also taught in teacher education crt is
not so much a school subject but a
pedagogy a world view that is what
american parents are objecting to during
the pandemic lockdowns parents got a
laptop window into their children's
education and many didn't care much for
what they saw
just as we see in the controversial and
viral videos from the libs of tick tock
twitter account these parents saw
teachers more interested in creating
good little activists than helping kids
read and count
but even worse that activism whether in
support of a galaxy of genders or the
marxist musings of black lives matter
contains a value system that many
parents do not share this brings us
squarely back to the question of whose
kids are they too many educators see
their views on race and gender not as a
competing value system but as a sacred a
priori truth that justifies defying
allegedly bigoted parents
this leaves parents with two options a
republican party that reacts to their
concerns even perhaps with too much
overreach or a democrat party that just
has its head in the sand but democrats
need to understand that this issue is
not going away and telling americans
that crt and trans ideology in the
schools is great and also it doesn't
exist is not going to cut it
hillary clinton famously said in the
1990s that it takes a village to raise a
child today that maxim is being tested
in very real ways everyone wants
teachers to care for and about their
students but not everybody wants those
teachers to mold the minds of kids into
mirrors of their progressive ideologies
on the most basic and deepest questions
many parents still want to have the
final say
the year of the parent may well usher in
republican majorities in congress come
november but this issue is far bigger
than politics parents want a hand on the
steering wheel of their kids lives and
education they don't want self-driving
children guided by left-wing shibboleths
so far they seem to be winning the
cultural battle to take back control and
that shows no sign of stopping
i'm david marcus columnist and author of
charade the coveted lies that crushed a
nation
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes